الى فرنسا اعلنت المدعيه العملي باريس ان
متقاعده الذي اعترف بقتل ثلاثه اكراد في
باريس قال انه ذهب اولا الى بلده في ضاحيه
ساندوني الشماليه للعاصمه باريس لارتكاب
جرائم قتل ضد اجانب وذكرت المدعيه العامه
الفرنسيه انه تخلى عن التوجه الى ضواحي
باريس لقله الموجودين وصعوبه اعاده ملئ
سلاحه وانه فضل تنفيذ الهجوم في منطقه
مقتظه واضافت ان الرجل البالغ من العمر 69
عاما اعترف بانه يكون كراهيه للاجانب حتى
اصبحت حاله مرضيه تماما
من باريس معي مراسل عربي يا حسين اهلا بك
يعطيك الف عافيه على هاليومين اللي كان
مفترض ان تكون هادئه بعيد الميلاد هناك
تفاصيل عن التحقيقات مثيره ما هي
ريما شكرا لك
تفاصيل بعضها ذكرته في مقدمه الخبر والبعض
الاخر يتمثل في قول المعتدي طبعا انا
هناجئت الى المنطقه التي شهدت مواجهات
عنيفه بين الغاضبين الاكراد وعناصر الشرطه
امس سيارات مقلوبه واخرى محترقه وايضا
وجهات تو محل تجاريه وجهاز زجاجيه تضررت
جرح 31 شرطيا ومتظاهر واحد واوقفه احد عشر
مثيرا للشغب كما قال الشرطه اعود الى
المعلومات التي نشرتها النيابه العامه في
باريس بالاضافه الى ما ذكرت المعتدي قال
انه كان يرغب في تفريق كل الرصاصات التي
كانت في حوزته ضد اجانب ضد مهاجرين مهما
كانت جنسيتهم كما انه كان يريد
الانتحار كان يريد ان الرصاصه الاخيره
التي كانت بحوزته على نفسه وقال انه منذ
ان تعرض منزله للسرقه عام 2016 اصبح يتم
حقدا مرضيا على المهاجرين اصبح راغبا في
الانتحار وفي قتل مهاجرين نقل بعض ظهر امس
المعتدي الى مصحه نفسيه تابعه لشرطه باريس
لان وضعه الصحي كما قال الطبيب الذي عينه
لم يسمح بالابقاء عليه اضمن الحبس
الاحتياطي ومدته وتسعون ساعه لكن المعتدي
لا يمكن ان يبقى ستا 96 ساعه ضمن الحبس
الاحتياطي نظرا لضروسيا الصحيه يعني لا
اصدق
او بمعركه حسين العلاقه بين الاكراد
وسلطات الفرنسيه جيده لماذا لم يمن
القيمون على الاكراد على المتظاهرين في
الشارع ومحدثين الشعب
سؤالك سؤالك ريما طرح بطريقه ما امس على
احد المسؤولين الاكراد في باريس فاقر بان
الوضع تجاوزنا كل تصريحات المسؤولين
الاكراد كما قال المتحدث باسم المجلس
الديمقراطي لكردستان في باريس كل تصريحات
المسؤولين الاكراد ذهبت في اتجاه التهدئه
وضبط الامور لكن كان هناك غضب كبير خصوصا
ان اشخاصا كانوا علامات من شاحنه صغيره
قالوا كلاما
وارسل اشارات مستفزه فكان الرد عليهم كما
قال هذا المسؤول الكردي بالفعل العلاقات
جيده جدا بين الاكراد بين فصائلهم
واحزابهم وجاليتهم هنا وبين السلطات
الفرنسيه اليوم الاول بعد قتل الثلاثي
الذي حصل الجمعه كان هادئ النسبيا راينا
مجموعات من الاكراد تحاول تهدائه الغاضبين
من الاكراد وتفصل بينهم وبين القوى
الامنيه لكن الامور امس تطورت بعد هذا
الاستفزاز الذي قام به من كانوا على شاحنه
صغيره الاشاره اخيره لو سمحتي لي الى ان
تصريحات المسؤولين الفرنسيين التي تلاحقت
امس المسؤولون الفرنسيون اكدوا دعمهم
للجاليه الكرديه وقالوا ان موقفنا الدعم
للاكراد ثابت لا يتزعزع كما قال حرفيا
وزير العدل الفرنسي
الى حد كبير نعم تصريحات المسؤولين
الاكراد اسهمت في التهدئه والامور تبدو
طبيعيه اليوم في باريس